[Music]
hi folks this is joshua skidmore with
fisher's space pen in boulder city
nevada
since covet is hit this year we've got
some new products that can keep your
family safe and healthy
as long as honor those in your love that
are loved ones that are front line
workers as well too
if you take a look here we have our
anti-microbial raw brass space pens
these are actually manufactured at 85
copper 15
zinc and the epa registered that copper
alloy is being antimicrobial
properties over here we have our first
responder thin line
series and what better way to give back
to a first responder than
support the communities that support
them each color line
has a charity that's associated with it
that we give back a portion of the sales
to support those first responders and
their efforts as well
all of these pens are available to get
customized and engraved you can come to
spacepen.com to learn about that more
and also about the charities we partner
these pens with as well
but you can come to boulder city nevada
and pick these pens up this holiday
season they are fantastic gifts